dude have you guys come across this
[ __ ] it's like a reddit
it's all over reddit i don't i i've
literally
only been on any reddit because of stuff
that ivan gets rid of sends me
i don't really understand it you can
like vote stuff up and stuff down wow it
sounds so old but um
dude this thing he was showing me is
[ __ ] hilarious
it's a tinder thing right where they
just show tinder
conversations
like before they date
or something like that
yeah and uh
like this is the tinder reddit page i
guess a community for discussing the
online dating app tinder sharing
conversations reviewing profiles and
more um
so this is so people are so weird dude
like people are so
[ __ ] weird
that i i don't you know how like people
are like well the world's gone to hell
and everyone's like at each other's
throats i am actually when i see [ __ ]
like this i'm surprised anyone is still
alive
because
people disagree on so much [ __ ] like
when i see [ __ ] like this this is the
one
um
this is what the person says all right
all right i gotta i just gotta say you
are absolutely stunning
um
and and then the person says you should
know i injured my foot on thursday so i
can't walk very far did you have a place
in mind
first of all just off to a [ __ ]
absolutely uh try it this is a travesty
already like want to go out yeah broke
my foot can we go close
uh
oh okay so well i guess i'm not getting
laid but yeah yeah let's go close what's
close to you
um so then the guy says ah damn sorry to
hear that i can take the train in i'm
from long island
so i really don't know the area
and then the person writes
i mean i can't even wow the person
writes
a potty mouth
i'm okay
and then
the okay so if this were me at that
point i'd be like i'd have to like scan
the conversation and be like what is the
potty mouth part
and this person then replies damn's a
potty word lol but i'm glad you're okay
and then the person writes back again
may you please not curse when you're
talking to me thanks
some mormon
dude to like what like why
like leave it alone hey hey guys
leave it alone right the most leave it
alone you should have left it alone
already way before like first of all the
broken foot thing i'm out dude this is
tinder right like dude i didn't even
meet you yet
how how amazing do you have to be
for me to even just
like this is just a profile you might be
a man for all i know
hey my foot broke do you have a place in
mind gotta come close already i'm like
okay this is already you're being
difficult sorry you broke your foot but
now i gotta take the trainer from long
island
and then he said oh damn sorry to hear
that sean sympathy
and then she says a potty mouth hmm
smorman dude leave it alone why even say
potty mouth [ __ ] just ghost them from
there
and then the guy says damn's a potty
word but uh i'm glad you're okay
don't say that and then the other person
may you please not curse it's already
over
you bored
get hobbies
right
unbelievable this [ __ ] is unbelievable
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
somebody said ned flanders has entered
the chat
it's great
here we go another one
this is great dude these tinder shits
was this too harsh it says forgive my
ignorance but what's an odp
somebody says google it
and then somebody wrote i tried to start
a conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ] google it
dude
i know who this guy is this is a guy i
got a pizza from once uh at la canada
imports down
uh on uh foothill boulevard and uh all
to kenyatta because i got pizza from and
he was doing it and he would always
[ __ ] get
put out the pizzas and pizza was so good
there and then one time he turned around
and he got a piece of pizza from his
wife and his wife says it's hot dude and
this makes well i'll tell you this part
at the end actually and he said she says
careful it's hot and he turned out to
round to me and under his breath he said
i know it's [ __ ] hot dude that's this
guy that's this guy on tinder now and
dude how much sense does this make he
was white and older and his and his wife
was asian and younger ow makes too much
sense man send scale off the charts dude
come on guess what race older white guy
talking to a younger female asian of
course
i know it's [ __ ] hot
basically what he was saying is should
have killed you all we had the chance
you know what i mean like i'm not saying
there was a chance or whatever that's
not me saying that i'm just doing it for
what he probably that was the tone of
the [ __ ] thing right
basically called her charlie is all i'm
saying but i'm just and that's not me
saying that i'm just saying what this is
the tony ad but dude this is amazing
forgive my ignorance but what's an odp
google it i tried to start a
conversation by giving you a dude this
is john malkovich
do you know what i mean like so pinpoint
accurate with his verbage i tried to
start a conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ]
google it
dude this is basically a line from in
the line of fire
that's what [ __ ] the bad guy says to
clint eastwood and i'll do it while i'm
pissing on your grave
i'll [ __ ] say i'll [ __ ] laugh
about it when i'm pissing on your grave
and then john malkovich comes in over
the phone i tried to start a
conversation by giving you the
opportunity to talk about something
you're presumably interested in
obviously i can [ __ ]
google it
um dude
also such a robot this is just a b this
is honestly just a.i dude this is ai
dating this is a robot trying to get his
[ __ ] bolts wet
this is an oh this is a this is a
[ __ ] robot trying to [ __ ] get his
get his [ __ ] uh
nuts and bolts just creamy dude hello i
would like my nuts and bolts creamy
forgive my ignorance
but what is an odp
google it
identifying [ __ ]
comments attitude
i try to start a conversation by giving
you the opportunity to talk about
something you're
presumably interested in
obviously i can
[ __ ] google it
[Music]
moon walks out
and then [ __ ] i wonder why that [ __ ]
plays by tupac
over his speakers he just opens his
mouth
dude it just goes
and his mouth opens and it goes wonder
why they call you [ __ ] wonder why they
call you [ __ ] as he moonwalks away dude
wow these are so fun dude what the [ __ ]
is up with dating apps
here we go i hate dating apps so much it
says
since you shared your batman story i
once had dreams of being a powerpuff
girl and then the guy said so were you
made from sugar spice and everything
nice and then the girl just writes
no
and then she says and if that line ever
works for you you should question why
and then he says it's from the intro to
powerpuff girls it's not a pickup line
lol
dude unreal did she know it or not it's
not a [ __ ] line it's from the intro
the [ __ ] that you brought up
dude
turn the combo on his [ __ ] ass
that girl's sitting on her [ __ ] right
now dude
it's from the [ __ ] you brought up
[Music]
oh my god dude unreal
one for the boys dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man had it rough the
past five years but we back after that
message you brought it up
[Music]
dude you brought up the powerpuff girls
oh you thought you knew more about girl
[ __ ] than i did well let me [ __ ] slam
it back to you and bring some up
undercover
and you don't even know about it and
then you get mad at me and dude let me
just chuck one down for the boys
it's another what
my dogs are in cells get the [ __ ] out of
here bud butters butters has a son i
never told you guys i won't talk about
it ever he has his son
dude one time for real better says his
son but it says a son i'm not joking he
has two sons
i'm not joking my dog one time i was i
used to hang out with this girl and she
came over once and we were hanging out
watching tv at my apartment we had sex
and when we got done dude we looked over
and butters was stuck inside her dog
didn't know didn't know what the [ __ ]
dude butters wouldn't come out
you know that's the dogs have like
penises that have like grappling hooks
that they go in and then they [ __ ]
open up and then it can't get out to
ensure insemination it's very [ __ ]
gross but that's what happens and
butters was looking at me like what the
[ __ ] going on dude and sure enough
insemination happened and butters had
two sons and she gave one away and then
had another one and then and then her
[ __ ] ex-boyfriend took it and she
cried a lot on social media about it
what the [ __ ] is life but that's what
happened so better son is out there
somewhere
these reddit shits are amazing let's
look at another one
dude he slammed her to a [ __ ]
bolivian dude
wow
unbelievable dude the guy the boys are
back aren't they huh
after that
after that dude
boys are back
oh i just did that one okay all right
when i just did that one this is good
because it clicks the checks the ones we
did one fire did that i had it to
[ __ ] change his name to one from one
higher huh
uh he had reading as an interest in his
bio a common one okay
so the guy writes so you like reading i
see what's the last book you read and
the best book you
read
and then somebody said oh oh oh oh
so he had reading in his bio
and then
she says so you like reading i see
what's the last book you read and the
best book you read and then the guy
writes [ __ ] off
oh dude and then she writes what why we
have reading as common interest i just
wanted to start a convo any any rights
[ __ ]
ciao
oh the boys are back
dude men had it rough for about eight
years and that's it thanks to this
italian speaking [ __ ] dude
[Music]
dude that's unreal what he did man oh
you thought we were gonna talk about
something you wanted to just because i
put it on my profile well [ __ ] you
got another thing and think coming
[Music]
oh dude chubby
slammed up duh duh
let the boys be boys
unbelievable dude what a dick that guy
is
you know
what a dick his name's tom that's
hilarious too and it's in and of itself
let's do another one dude these are too
fun we got to keep going wow god damn
dude this is fun i hope you're in your
car on a road trip and you just keep
[ __ ] driving and you're like i hope
this podcast never ends because that's
how i feel this one says how do i
respond please help this is just a guy
reaching out damn if you wait
damn it
dude
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
l y t-a-t-l-y n no granted that name is
stupid as [ __ ] okay but he says
damn if you were my teacher i'd be
tattling on all the other students just
to talk to you
and she writes back this is the best
are you [ __ ] stupid
it's taitlin [ __ ] idiot oh
[ __ ] dude the dudes had a good run for
about 14 minutes
women are back dude
unbelievable man
wow dude i still like well why is it
spelled tatlin
there should be an e in there
there should be an e in there you know
what dude she's actually wrong that
guy's not an idiot dude oh another one
for the [ __ ] boys she was technical
difficult or technic technicality
whatever the [ __ ] you know i mean
you know what i'm trying to say dude
disqualified
oh [ __ ] dude
god damn these ones are great
ah
i did it checked it off all right now
this one check it off um
got a headache from screaming at all and
i gotta sign it i gotta sign it oh my
nose about the bleed that's great is
this weird matched two weeks ago she's
nice
um sometimes i don't know who's who so i
guess this is
this is him so i heard of them they
sound cool they're that korean band yeah
spelled wrong but they're wrong there
but uh then they write yeah that's one
of the reasons why i matched with you
looking for a asian guy because i want
wagian babies okay so she's white
he writes whoa ha ha bit early to talk
about babies and then she writes no not
really i'm young but i def see myself
being a stay-at-home mom and i love
babies
they're going to be on my mind and i'm
always going to be planning
to have one or four maybe five holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
hey
you need to take a course on how to get
what you want
i mean this is absolutely insane dude
first of all in the beginning
it's racist
and then
also
absolutely not going to get what you
want even though that's the thing you're
talking about wanting okay
so sweetheart
and i don't mean to call you sweetheart
but
i am
don't be doing all that wow that's
actually
that person will be alone forever and
that's so sad um
this one's ironic it's called
sanjay
the so the girl writes hi
and then sanjay write oh wait no that's
too sanjay so hi and then she writes
i don't know who's who is this a girl
girl
no this is the guy i'm in jamaica for a
week what do i absolutely need to do
before i leave
and then they say something you're
interested in i guess
lol what am i to say and then they say
i don't know i figured you'd have some
ideas because you live here or you could
just say you'll show me around
and then they say i'm not a tour guide
honey i work lol
and then he says what do you do for work
she says i'm a travel agent dude
oh
unreal dude
attempts at your tour guide
oh my god the [ __ ] absolutely rare
um
embossed die cut sl self [ __ ] slam
you're a tour guide
oh my god dude the foil embossed the die
cut the limited edition ultra rare
self slam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
unbelievable bro
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy crazy
[Music]